This program is being presented to you
by the Heraeus International Winter
School on gravity and light.
Hello and welcome back to the fifth
tutorial of the W. E. Heraeus
International Winter School on gravity
and light.
Today about tangent spaces.
Again, we will start with a few true or
false questions
to spark discussions in the tutorials
and here for you as a self-test.
So, we have to tick the correct
statements, but not the incorrect ones.
A.
A tangent vector to a differentiable
manifold
has a length and a direction.
Well,
well, you could ask you that the
direction is given by the tangent vector
as a new kind of terminology.
It certainly has no length in a general
setting
because as you will see in one of the
following lectures,
a length
is only defined when you have a metric
on your manifold.
And in general, you have not, so
the first option is wrong.
A tangent vector to a differentiable
manifold must not be zero.
Well, let's have a look at the
definition of a tangent vector.
The tangent vector V
was defined by curve gamma
at a point P
by its action on a function F on the
manifold.
And how does it act?
Well, you have to compose the function
with the respective curve,
take the derivative of it,
and evaluate at the point lambda naught.
What is lambda naught?
Well, it is the parameter value where
the curve gamma takes the value P. So,
gamma of
lambda naught
is P.
Now, if we have a curve gamma which
remains stationary at the point P, so
imagine you have your
manifold
M,
here your point P,
and your curve gamma does something,
and at the point P, it stays there for a
time, and then carries on.
This derivative will be zero, of course.
And the tangent vector would be the zero
map from C infinity M to R.
So, yeah, it can be zero.
So, this second option is wrong as well.
A tangent vector to a differentiable
manifold
maps a function on the manifold to the
real numbers.
Well, I just gave you the definition of
a tangent vector.
Here you take
a function
on the manifold,
and here
you get a real number.
So, a tangent vector is mapping a
function on the manifold to the real
numbers.
So, this is correct, and we can tick it.
A tangent vector to a differentiable
manifold is of the same dimension as the
manifold.
What is the dimension of a vector? The
answer is we have we didn't define
dimensions of vectors.
A vector is only a vector in the context
of a whole vector space, and this vector
space may carry a dimension,
but not the vector itself.
So, this option is wrong as well.
A tangent vector to a differentiable
manifold arises as the velocity to some
curve through the vector space point.
Yes, this is true.
We defined these velocities,
showed that they constitute a vector
space,
and any element of this vector space we
call a tangent vector. So, by its very
definition,
this option is right.
Question B.
The tangent vec- uh the tangent space
TPM to a D-dimensional differentiable
manifold
is of the dimension two times dimension
of M.
Well, no. This is to dilute you.
We will see the dimension is only one
times dim M.
Two times dim M would be the dimension
of the tangent bundle, to which we will
come later. So, this option is wrong.
The tangent space can be defined at
every point P of M.
Yeah, why not?
Let's again take a look at the
definition of the tangent space TPM.
The tangent space TPM
is just defined
as the collection
of all velocities
of curves through this point P.
Yeah, where where where gamma is just a
curve
through this point P.
And here
we didn't make any restriction on the
point P, so it is valid for every point
P. There's no sense no
no real reason to restrict it. So,
this option is right.
The tangent space TPM is no real vector
space because its elements are only
tangent vectors.
Uh this is of course wrong because in
the lectures you showed
that you can equip
this tangent space with an addition and
and scalar multiplication,
and you showed that
the axioms for a vector space hold. So,
of course, it is a vector space, and
these elements are called tangent
vectors because
we call this vector space the tangent
space. But nevertheless, it is a vector
space.
The tangent space TPM to a D-dimensional
differentiable manifold admits a linear
bijection to the vector space RD
plus
circ,
where plus shall be the component-wise
addition on tuples of real numbers,
and circ the component-wise
multiplication with a scalar.
This is of course true because in the
lectures you checked that TPM
to a D-dimensional differentiable
manifold in fact is a D-dimensional real
vector space.
And it is a fact that every
finite-dimensional vector space with
dimension D
to the real numbers
is
um isomorphic to the vector space RD,
which is written here.
And a linear bijection between vector
spaces is just a vector space
isomorphism.
So,
this is true.
The tangent space TPM
has no tangent vectors in common with a
tangent space TQM for a different point
Q,
which is not M and not P.
This is right.
As you can see on the definition of your
tangent space.
It is defined via
these objects,
which are defined by collections of
curves through P,
the point P. And of course, this
collection looks different at any point
P.
So, true.
Question C.
If UX is a chart for a D-dimensional
differentiable manifold,
then
the coordinate maps XY mapping from the
chart domain U to the real numbers
are
with I running from one to the dimension
of the manifold are only continuous, not
differentiable.
Well,
first, it is true
that the coordinate maps
are defined as being continuous maps
into the real numbers with continuous
inverse.
So, pictorially, we have
the chart domain U,
and coordinate maps map into the real
numbers.
This is the coordinate map
XY.
And here on this level, you can only
check for continuity because here you
have no structure to
talk about differentiation.
But now we can look at what happens in a
chart.
And here we may take the same chart X,
which is very convenient.
So, a chart maps into
RD.
And on this level, down in the chart, we
can check this function
not only for continuity, but also for
differentiability.
So, here we have
XI
after
X inverse,
which is just
the identity map
on RD,
and of this identity map,
the Ith component,
which is of course differentiable.
And when we are talking about a
differentiable manifold,
then the chart transition maps into
different charts,
let's call call them Y, are
differentiable, so this
differentiability carries over to the
differentiability
in a different chart and we can say that
this function on the manifold level is
continuous because it's differentiable
because this notion doesn't depend on
the chosen chart anymore. So yes,
we can tick this.
The coordinate maps are
I'm sorry.
Question was whether they are not
differentiable.
And this is of course
false.
If UX is a chart for a D-dimensional
differentiable manifold, then
these objects DX1
point P to DXT to the
at the point P constitute a basis of TP
star M.
Well,
we can show that they do not constitute
any basis, but special cases basis,
which is the dual basis for the
coordinate basis on TPM and
from there it follows that they
constitute a basis of TP star M. Let's
show this.
So,
what is the condition for a dual basis?
An element of this basis
DXI
point P
acting
on a basis vector
del del XJ P
shall be
just delta I J.
And this we can check via the very
definition of the gradient.
So,
left hand side is defined
by the action of this vector on
on this function.
So it is
just
del del XJ
point P
acting on the function
XA.
And this is also just a definition what
is denoted here.
It is
the
partial derivative with respect to the
Jth entry
of this function in question
composed
with the inverse of the chart map
denoted down here
and evaluated at the chart image of the
point P.
And she in the bracket
we just have the identity map
on RD
and of this map
the Ith component.
And taking the partial derivative with
respect to the Jth entry of this map
yields just delta
IJ
which is
exact
what we need in order for the condition
for the dual basis to hold.
So, we checked that these elements
constitute the dual basis of TPM.
So they constitute a basis of TP of TP
star M.
So this is true.
For the basis
del del X1 P
to del del XDP of TPM, there's no dual
basis in the dual space.
This we just checked, so we can tick it.
It is
wrong
because we gave a dual basis, right? I'm
sorry.
Are the components of the vector X with
respect to the chart induced basis
are
DXI sub P
X.
Well, of course this is true.
Because
um
Let's again write down what the
components of a vector were.
A vector arises as a
velocity of a curve at a point P
and was defined by the action of a
function F
while taking
the function
after
the curve
the the of the derivative
evaluating
at the point lambda naught where lambda
naught again was just the parameter
value where the curve takes the value P.
So here
we now can insert
our
chart map
the
inverse of the chart map here and here
just the chart map
which just collapses to the identity, so
we can do this.
Take the derivative
evaluating
and now we may apply apply
our multi-dimensional chain rule because
we can put brackets here and here.
So what does the multi-dimensional chain
rule do?
We have to differentiate this inner
function
and of this inner function
the Ith component.
Evaluate at lambda zero
and then comes the partial derivative
with respect to the Ith entry
of the outer function.
So,
DI
the outer function F
of the X
inverse
evaluating at X after gamma of lambda
zero.
So X of gamma
of lambda zero.
1 2
3.
Here
you can recognize
just the basis vectors with respect to
the chart map X
acting on the function F.
So,
an abbreviation for this is del
del XA
point P
acting on the function F.
So these guys
are the components.
of our vector.
If we now
apply
this covector
on this vector written here
we can extract just these components.
Let me show it to you.
Just have to apply
this gradient
del DX
J
point P to our vector
V gamma P.
And by definition of the gradient
we get the vector V gamma
P
acting on the function
XJ
and
we know what what this vector is doing.
We calculated it here.
Just have to put XJ the place of F
and this we already calculated up
here
or
along this calculation we just yield
delta IJ.
If we put XJ here.
So,
we get this
prefactor the components
times
delta
JI
and of course
this extracts
the Jth
component of the vector.
So the statement certainly
is true.
The expression
DXA sub P
acting on the basis vector del del XA
sub P
yields the dimension of the manifold.
But how could the dimension of the
manifold come into play here?
Well, let's take a look at this.
We have
this covector
DXA
acting on
this vector.
And we already calculated this
up here.
Right?
And we just got
delta IJ.
Now, I and J are both A.
So, we write delta AA.
And now we have to remember our
summation convention.
Here, we have an invisible sum sign
with A running from run one to the
dimension of the manifold,
which was D.
Summing over all of these numbers delta
AA,
which are just one by definition.
So, we have
the sum from one to D over the one.
And this
is D, the dimension of a manifold.
So, this statement is true.
Exercise two.
Virtuous are use of the symbol del over
del XI sub P.
This exercise is about getting familiar
with this notion and a few other notions
we introduced.
Question. For a smooth function F and a
chart UX, provide the definition of the
expression del F over del XI P.
This looks very much like the
undergraduate analysis
partial derivative.
And
to certain extent, it is exactly this.
But here, it is slightly different
because we have a function F
mapping from the manifold M
to the real numbers.
Function F.
And this we can't
differentiate
because M carries no differentiable
structure.
But
we can use a chart map,
which maps down
into some RD.
I'm sorry.
So, that we can regard the function
F
after X inverse mapping from RD to R.
And here, we can decide for
differentiability and calculate these
derivatives.
And when it's about to calculate the Ith
partial derivative, well, of this
function, we can take the partial
derivative with respect
to the Ith entry,
which then is just
del
I
of the function down
in the chart.
And of course, we can't put in the point
P directly. We have to put it in down in
the chart.
So, at the point X
of P.
This is the translation
of the symbol above.
Question. Show that for overlapping
charts UX and VY and VY, one has
this relation.
Here,
we will start
with the right-hand side
because we already know something about
the right-hand side.
We did it in the first exercise.
So,
delta AB
can arise
as
the derivative
in the chart
X
with respect to the Ith entry.
No, A is below, so we have to
write B here
at the point P
of the chart
map
X
A.
This will just evaluate to delta AB,
which we showed in the previous
exercise.
We can evaluate the symbol.
This is
del
B
of
XA after
X inverse
at the point X of P.
And now, we can insert here
the identity
written as Y inverse after Y,
where Y
is our second chart map.
So, we may do this.
And then put brackets around these
functions XA
after Y inverse
and around
Y after
X inverse.
And evaluate at the point
X of P.
Now, we may employ our multi-dimensional
chain rule.
Which goes like this.
Take this derivative of the inner
function
or rather of the Mth component of the
inner function.
So, del B
of
the Mth components
of the inner function
evaluated at the point
and multiplied
and sum over M
with
the partial derivative with respect to
the Mth entry of the outer function.
XA after Y inverse.
And evaluate at point X of P evaluated
at Y after X inverse. So, here we really
have to put
Y
after X inverse
of X of P.
One, two,
three.
Now, of course, X inverse cancels X and
we just can put Y of P here in in this
bracket.
And then, we can translate these
expressions
back
into
our symbol.
But now, we don't have F.
We have
chart maps X and Y.
So,
this here reads
down here
XB because we're using the chart X.
And
differentiate with respect to the Bth
entry.
And which function do we differentiate?
Well, it's
YM.
But hang on.
M is written out here,
not here directly at Y.
Well, this doesn't do any harm because
for the
leftmost function, it doesn't make any
difference if we write
M here or here.
Right? Because M indicates
the
because this function
takes values in RD.
And M just picks one of these values.
And therefore, it doesn't matter if you
pick the value at the end
or
if you say, "Well, just regard only the
YMth component function." Right?
So, we we can
write this here.
At the point P.
And here, it reads
del of the function XA
with respect to the chart map Y.
And here, we have put the M.
At the point P.
And this is what we had to show. We have
to swap those expressions, but we can do
this. And
we got delta AB.
Now, question.
After inserting Y inverse after Y,
where Y is another chart map on the same
chart domain U
at an appropriate position in the
definition of the left-hand side
in this expression.
We shall use
the undergraduate multi-dimensional
chain rule to show that it equals the
right-hand side.
Okay, let's do this.
Therefore,
we again have to translate this
expression,
which we already did a few times, so
this will just be
del
del i
of
f
after x inverse
at the point x of p.
This is a translation of this.
And now we can insert right
here the identity map y inverse after y
because it takes values of
the manifold
and it again gives a value in the
manifold.
So, this is the right spot for the
identity on the manifold.
Now,
we can again put brackets around
the right functions here, but around
this function
and here
around
this function.
Employ the chain rule.
So,
first del i of the inner function
and here of the
mth
component
times
the derivative
del m of the outer function
at this point.
Now,
this again
yields just the identity map
on the manifold, so we can just put y of
p
at the place of this expression.
And then we can translate
this expressions back to our symbols and
we get
del y
m
over
del x
i at the point p
times
del f over
del y m
at the point p.
So, we showed
that this left-hand side really yields
this right-hand side.
Question.
Do the dim m many quantities defined by
the left-hand side of the above
expression constitute the components of
a tensor?
If so, what are the valence and the rank
of the tensor?
Well, we will see
that
they in fact constitute the components
of a tensor and it will be a 0 1 tensor.
So,
what do we have to check for this?
Well,
of course, you can expand a covector
omega
if you have a chart map x
into components with with respect to
this chart map
and of course, the chart induced bases
of the dual space
d x i
p.
And
you can employ a different chart
y
and here
it looks like this.
Components with respect to the y chart
times the chart induced
basis elements with respect to the y
chart.
And in order for those two expansions to
yield the same covector on the real
world omega,
you have to ensure
that the relation between
these components in the x chart and
these components in the y chart
fulfills a property
which you may call
uh
tensor component transformation property
or something like this.
And you can calculate
it to be
this condition.
Omega
in
the x chart
so the ith component in the x chart
has to be
a linear combination of the components
in the y chart. In which con-
combination? Well, it's given by
these
numbers.
Del y j
over del x i
at the point p.
And now we can compare with what we
calculated above.
If
these are components in the x chart and
these are components in the y chart,
the linear combination has to be with
respect to these objects.
And really,
here we have these exact objects.
So,
the
tensor components transformation law for
a 0 1 tensor
is fulfilled.
So, these del f over del x i p really
constitute components of a
tensor.
So,
this is the valence 0 1
and
the rank
is 1 because it is the sum of the 0 and
the and the 1.
Exercise three. Transformation of vector
components.
Understanding the vector component
transformation law the pedestrian way.
Here this about calculating real
components of real vectors.
Therefore, we have given a manifold R2
equipped with standard topology and with
an atlas consisting of two charts.
First, the identity map on whole R2
given here.
And second, the map y on whole R2 given
here.
First question is about calculating
these objects.
This we can just do in a very
straightforward way by
remembering the definition of these
objects,
which was del j
of x y
i after y inverse
at the point
y of p.
Now we see, in order to calculate those
objects, we have to know what the
inverse of the coordinate map y is.
So, let's calculate it.
This will just be a system of equations,
where
y1
of a b
equals a
and y2
of a b
equals b plus a cubed.
This we can invert.
And here we can use the first equation
to write b
plus
a cubed is just y1 cubed.
So, y1
of a b
cubed.
So, we calculated the inverse map y
inverse
of
two numbers
mhm
u v
will just be the first number again.
And the second number minus the first
number to the power of three.
So,
v minus
u cubed.
Good.
And we already know what
x after y inverse
does with two numbers because x is just
the identity map. So, again we get u
and v minus minus u cubed.
Now,
now we can calculate these four objects
separately.
We can start with
the LX1
over the Y1
P.
This is del one of
X
one after Y inverse
at
the point
Y of P.
So,
del one of X1 after Y inverse means
we have to differentiate this function
which just gives you with respect to the
first entry
here you
which yields one irrespective of this
point.
Get one.
Now,
what about the second component?
It's again a state one, but now X2 after
Y inverse
Y of P.
Now, if we want to put numbers into
this, we have to specify
our point P by two numbers. So, we call
P
let's say
A and B.
So,
we evaluate at the Y of A and B.
And Y of A and B is written up here.
This
A
plus A and B plus
A cubed.
Now,
we have to differentiate the second
component
with respect to the first entry
and this yields
minus two
U squared.
So,
minus two
and here we don't call it U, we call it
A. So, minus two
A squared.
And now we may turn
to the next two
objects. Del X1
over del
Y2
P.
This is del one
X1
after Y inverse.
No, here we have
del two
at Y of P.
So, first
component with respect to the second
entry
just yields zero.
And the last object is del X2 over del
Y2
the point P.
So, del two
X2
sec Y inverse
Y of P.
And what does this yield?
Well,
the second component with respect to the
first
with respect to the second entry
yields a one again
irrespective of the point where we
evaluate.
So, these are the first the four
objects.
Yeah.
Now,
now here's a text
where
the
transformation of vector components is
being recalled.
So,
a vector was defined by its action on a
smooth function
like this.
And we already did it in the first
exercise.
You can extract components with respect
to a basis
by
inserting the identity map here
and applying the multi-dimensional chain
rule and you get these components here.
And these components we want to
calculate for this specific curve.
So, let's do it.
We will start with the components in the
X map.
gamma X
And here the first component
at the parameter value lambda naught.
This is by the definition
of this abbreviation
the coordinate map
after
the curve gamma
of this the first component
the derivative of this
and evaluating at
parameter value lambda naught.
Now, X is just the identity map.
So, X after gamma
of parameter lambda just gives
lambda and minus lambda.
So, we have to differentiate the first
component of this map lambda
which of course gives a one
irrespective of this parameter value
lambda naught.
Now, proceeding the same way for the
second component
two
we get this time a minus one.
Now, turn to the Y map.
gamma dot Y1
lambda naught
where this just is the Y map after gamma
first component derivative
lambda naught.
Now, we need to compose this
curve with the Y
map. So, Y after gamma of lambda is what
we need.
Now, we have to insert
the point lambda and minus lambda
into the map Y
which is noted here.
So, we get lambda and minus lambda
plus lambda cubed.
Again, lambda
minus lambda
plus lambda cubed.
And now we have to take the derivative
of the first component
again, just one.
For the second component
we get
Oh,
here I should say
gamma.
two
Now, we have to differentiate this
component which gives minus one plus
three times
the argument squared.
So, minus one
plus three times lambda naught
squared.
And we calculated all four components.
Now, to the last part of this exercise.
With the result of the first question,
how could you have obtained
the components
gamma dot
X
from the components gamma dot Y?
Well, this question of course is asking
for the transformation behavior of
vector components.
Which is quite easy to derive because we
have to recall
um how you can calculate vector
components.
This
goes by
this expression.
X after gamma
I
differentiated
and evaluated at the point lambda naught
and here we can just insert the identity
map written as Y inverse after Y.
So, this is X after Y inverse after Y
after gamma
I've component derivative
at lambda naught
and now we have to employ the chain
rule.
I can put brackets here and here
and get
the derivative of the mth component of
this here.
So,
Y after
gamma
m
prime
of lambda naught
times the mth partial derivative m
of the outer function
X after
Y
inverse
I
because here we can put the I
here
I and evaluating at
lambda naught inserted into the inner
function. So, at
Y after
gamma
at lambda naught.
So,
here we see
just the definition
of this gamma Y
dot
m
Right? So, the components of the
velocity
in the
chart map Y.
And
of course
in in the chart map X
we get the linear combination of these
components and this linear combination
is given by this expression here.
And what is this expression? Well,
this is just a symbol and we can train
translate it into the symbol
by del
X
I
over del Y m
evaluated at
this point gamma of lambda naught.
Which is just
our P because this lambda naught we we
always define this way.
So,
this is the transformation law
for
vector components
and this law we could have employed to
calculate
for example, the components in the X map
from the components in the Y map. We
didn't have to calculate these
explicitly.
So, how can we do this?
So, now let's let's check that we
actually were able to do this.
For the first
component
we get this linear combination
gamma
dot Y one
times
del X
m
one
over
del Y one
at
P
or let me denote
the expression for P gamma of lambda
naught
plus
the second
component in the Y map.
Now here
the two
below
to gamma of
lambda naught.
These objects we calculated
in the first question and these in the
second question.
So, we can read them off.
This is
one for the first component and minus
one plus three lambda naught squared for
the second component.
So, here a one
and here a minus one plus three
lambda naught
squared
for the second component.
Now
we have to read off these objects from
the first exercise.
Here we got
a one for the second derivative for the
first derivative and a zero for the
second one.
So,
one
and here zero
and in total we get one.
Which we can compare with our previous
result
where we also got a one.
Now we can do this for the second
component as well.
Gamma
two X
prime lambda naught
equals
gamma dot Y oops Y one times del X two
now
over del Y
one
at the point gamma of lambda naught
plus gamma dot
Y two times
del X two
over del Y two at gamma of lambda
naught.
Now we can read off again.
For
the components again we have one and
minus one plus three lambda naught
squared.
So,
this
and we have to read off these two
objects from above.
Where we got
minus two
a squared
but for a we have to insert
the first component
of the point
P equals gamma of lambda naught.
So,
minus two
and
the first component
in the Y map can be seen here is just
lambda naught. So,
minus two
lambda naught squared.
And I see I made a mistake in the
previous
exercise.
Here of course when we differentiate a
cube
we should have got minus three a
squared.
And here it should also read minus
three.
And the second object just gives a one.
So, here we get the one.
Now we can put this together and see
that these expressions cancel.
This is minus three lambda naught
squared
plus
minus one
three lambda naught squared
and we just get minus one which now is
the right answer.
Here.
Exercise four, the gradient.
Here you will see
a
special property of the covector named
gradient you introduced.
First we have to start
with a notion of level sets.
So, given a function F on a manifold M
let me
draw a picture.
So, this shall be
a manifold M
and
the function F
shall map to the reals
and we can draw the level sets of this
function. So, the sets where the
function takes same values which could
maybe
look
like
like this.
Here it takes value C1, here C2 and here
C3.
And these sets
are are defined like this.
A level set
for a constant C
is defined by all the points P in the
manifold
at which the function takes this value
C, like I drew it here.
Now, the question is
to formulate the condition for a curve
gamma
to take values solely in one of the
level sets of a function F.
So, we want to formalize
this intuition that a curve
gamma
only remains
for example, in this first level set C.
Goes maybe like
this.
Well,
what does this curve gamma have to
fulfill?
Of course, if we
Mhm, if we look at the point at any
parameter lambda
the point of the curve
the function F should yield
the specific constant C. So,
we shall have
this in order for gamma
to lie in
the level set of the function F with
respect to the constant C, right? This
has to
hold it for
all lambda
in R.
So, we can say
the composition of the function F
and the curve gamma
has to be identical to the constant
function
C.
At any
parameter time
lambda we shall get
when we compose F with the curve, the
constant C, right?
Now,
we have to show that if we take the
gradient
of this function
and um if we let it act on the velocity
vector
V
uh of this curve
then we shall get zero, like it is
written here.
So, let's calculate this.
We take the gradient
of the function F
the point P in the level set
let it act on a velocity vector
to a curve gamma
through this point P.
Now, by definition of the gradient
this is
this vector applied to this function.
So, V gamma P
applied to the function F.
And now, by definition
of the
velocity
this is
the composition of F
and the curve
of this composition the derivative
at
parameter value lambda naught.
And again
lambda naught
is the parameter where the curve takes
the value P.
And now
we have to use the condition to the
curve gamma
namely that gamma is a curve which lies
solely in a level set.
And we saw for such curves gamma
this composition
always yields a constant function.
So, here we're taking the derivative of
a constant function
which gives zero.
So, really the gradient of a function
annihilates
the vectors
to go to curves which remain entirely in
the level set of this function.
Exercise five.
Is there a well-defined sum of curves?
In the lectures
you defined the sum of curves with
respect to a specific chart
in order to define the sum of tangent
vectors to these curves. And here it is
about this construction and to see
whether this is useful
to to really define a sum of curves and
not only of the vectors.
But let's go at least step by step.
First, we consider again the topological
manifold R2 with the standard topology
and equip it with
the specific
atlas.
First mapping R2
with the identity map
and mapping R2 with this map Y
to R2.
First question is whether A is a C
infinity atlas.
Well, for a C infinity atlas, we have to
check whether the chart transition maps
from X to Y and from Y to X are C
infinity.
So, therefore we need first the inverse
maps, which is
quite easy.
For X inverse
for X because it is just the identity.
So, the inverse is also the identity and
maps AB
to AB.
For Y
we have to solve a system of equations.
We set Y1 of AB
to A like prescribed here.
Y2 of AB
to
B times E to the A and have to solve
this for A and B.
The first one we can already solve. A is
Y1
of AB.
And here we can insert the first
equation and get B times E to the Y1 of
AB
divide through this and get B.
So, B is
Y2 of AB
over
Yeah, over E
to the Y1
of AB.
Right? So,
Y inverse
just maps
A and B
to
the second over E to the first. So,
Well, well, first to the first
A and then what I said, the second over
E to the first.
So,
B is the second
and E to the first is E to the
A.
And now, we have to check
two functions for the C infinity
property.
First
let's take X inverse
after Y
which just maps
AB
to this expression because X inverse
doesn't do anything further with it.
So, we get A
and B
times E to the A.
Well, is this C infinity?
Of course, it is.
First component
is just mapping AB to A
which is of course C infinity and second
component as well. Here we have
the product of two C infinity functions,
which is again C infinity.
So, um this
is C infinity
of M.
Right?
Um not of M.
But of R2.
To R2.
So,
the second chart transition map would be
Y inverse
after X.
Mapping
AB
first again to I AB and then to A and B
over E to the A.
So, A
and B
over E to the A.
Which is again C infinity
R2
because here we have a smooth function
which we can readily see. Here we have
the quotient of two smooth functions
and importantly
in the
numerator
we have a function which is only
positive.
So, it is never zero and
now we know that the composition is C
infinity. If it was zero at some point,
this would fail, but here it doesn't.
Now, second question.
On M we now consider two curves.
Gamma and delta.
Gamma mapping lambda to lambda and one
and delta mapping lambda lambda to one
and lambda.
Now question is
without referring to any chart
can we give the sum gamma plus delta of
these curves?
And the answer of course is
no.
Our topological manifold or our manifold
is R2
and one might think well it's R2 so we
can just add two bits of numbers but
this isn't true.
Our manifold
is just the space of all our positions
and not a vector space at all.
So and without vector space structure we
can't add points and
without vector space structure we can't
add curves.
Vector spaces
are our chart domains our our chart
um
images so
this are two and this are two
they carry a vector space structure but
here we asking if we could add two
curves without referring to any chart.
So again no we can't.
Now we may try to
give the sum of those curves with
respect to a certain chart and this is
asked here.
We first shall calculate the
representatives of the curves
in the charts illustrate them and look
where they intersect. So step by step.
The representative of
the curve gamma in the X chart
is of course given by this.
And it
takes lambda
and gives lambda one composed with the
identity map.
So again
lambda one.
Now for the second curve
we get one lambda.
So this we may also do for
the chart map Y
where we put in lambda
get lambda one first
and this we have to put into the chart
map Y.
So we get lambda one times e to the
lambda.
So lambda and
e to the lambda.
For the second curve
we get first one and lambda
and with the chart map we get one
and lambda times e to the one.
So one
And this curves
we may illustrate. So here
in the X chart
well this is our
R2
here we have
X1
here we have X2.
The curve gamma is just a horizontal
line
with height one.
Imagine this being horizontal.
And
the curve
delta well let me draw it more
straightly.
And the curve delta is just a vertical
line
intersecting
the one
at the X1 axis.
So this is the curve delta.
And of course
they intersect here
at So I should specify this is
actually X after gamma
and this
is X after delta so they are the images
in the chart of the curves.
And they intersect here
in the point
one one
at the parameter value lambda naught
equals one.
So this is the parameter value
where
this curve the first curve yields the
intersection point.
And lambda one is the parameter value
for the second curve
but it also is one.
Right? At one both curves intersect each
other.
Now in the second chart.
Here we have again R2
Y1
Y2
and the first curve is the graph of the
function e to the lambda right? The
Y1
um coordinate is
is lambda and the Y2 is e to the lambda.
So we get
something like
this.
Intersecting
e here.
No intersecting one here actually.
And the second curve
remains
constant with respect to the
first component
and
so here
so it's a horizontal it's a vertical
line
here.
So what about the intersection point?
Well we see
for lambda equals one we have one and e
and here for lambda equals one we also
have one and e.
So they intersect at the intersection
point
one e
where the first curve has to take the
parameter value one
and
the second curve
as well.
So let me draw the names again. This is
Y after gamma this is Y after delta. So
you see of course with respect to
different chart maps
curves
may look quite different.
Here especially this curve.
The
curve gamma.
Now
we may give the sum of both curves in
this chart
which is
asked in the next exercise
or in the next question.
Now it's about to recall this procedure
from the lecture where you
added
those two curves
and then subtracted
one times the intersection point
in order that the intersection curve
which may
look like this
again
passes this point.
And then you could
lift this curve again to the manifold by
using this chart map X to the inverse
then you you get a curve in the real
world.
So let's do this for those two curves
this procedure.
We want to give the sum of two curves in
the real world in
first with respect to the X chart.
So
curve sigma X of lambda
shall live in the real world.
So we take X inverse after our
construction on the
chart level.
X inverse of
the sum of both curves
lambda plus
lambda naught
lambda plus lambda one so this is the
sum of both curves in the chart
and we subtract subtract the
intersection point
like this.
This we calculated.
So here we have to put
lambda plus one because lambda naught
and lambda one were both one.
Now we can
plug these values into our curves.
Here.
Here we get
lambda + 1
and 1
minus 1 and lambda + 1.
Minus the intersection point, which was
just 1 and 1.
And actually we wanted to give the sum
of the curves, not the difference. I'm
sorry.
Here.
So this evaluates to X inverse of
lambda + 1
plus 1 minus 1
so lambda + 1.
And
plus lambda + 1
minus 1
so again lambda + 1.
And X inverse was the identity map, so
we really get just lambda + 1
and lambda + 1.
Right?
The same we can do for the Y map.
Now with Y inverse
Y after gamma
at lambda plus lambda naught
plus
Y after delta
at lambda plus lambda naught
minus
Y after
gamma
at lambda naught.
Putting everything in
we get
first
lambda plus lambda naught and E to the
lambda plus lambda naught.
So lambda naught was 1.
So lambda plus
and E to the lambda plus 1, which is
just E
times E to the lambda.
Then we get a 1
and lambda + 1
because we're putting in
lambda + 1
and E.
So
E plus
E lambda
minus the intersection point
which was
1 and E.
So we have Y inverse
of
lambda + 1 plus 1 minus 1
so again lambda + 1
and here
E
times E to the lambda
plus E minus E
plus E lambda so
E
times E to the lambda
plus E times lambda.
Now we have to use the inverse
of Y
which we calculated
up here.
The first entry
is kept and then we have the quotient of
the second and E to the first.
So the first entry is kept
and the quotient of the second
E times E to the lambda
plus E lambda
over E
to the lambda plus 1.
I will use this space to draw the
result.
I have to to
give the result.
This is lambda
plus 1
and
well this cancels to 1
and this cancels
to lambda
times E to the minus lambda.
So 1
plus lambda
times E to the minus lambda
would be
the sum
with respect to the Y chart
of the two curves.
So this with respect to the X chart
and this
with respect to the Y chart.
Actually
this question was about this calculation
for the Y chart. I just did them both.
Here.
Now we can draw those two curves
in the real world.
R
R2
and R2 of course
you can draw like this
because it is just two bits.
Now um curve sigma X
is this
straight line
through the points 1 1 and 0 0 for
example.
1 and 0 0.
Of course maybe like this.
And
this curve sigma Y
is a little bit more complicated.
So we are back with a
plot
of the second curve.
Sigma sigma sigma Y of lambda
which looks somehow
like this in the real world.
And well they are intersecting in the
point 1
1.
And we easily see we already saw it with
this expressions for the curves that
they do not coincide.
So
we saw this concept of adding curves
down in the chart and then lifting the
sum up is not invariant under the choice
of chart, so it is really not useful.
Now we saw
that
this addition doesn't make any sense.
But
what about the velocities with respect
to this curves
at the intersection point?
This is what this question is about.
We shall compare those two velocities
and we will do so with the components of
the velocities. We already saw how to do
this expansion in the components.
Uh the components of the first velocity
we will now denote by
the curve
dots.
We have to specify the chart
and we look at the first component.
So
and um
of course at the intersection point of
both curves
which is zero.
Cuz at zero we get for sigma X 1 and 1
and for sigma Y 1
and also 1.
So they were defined by taking the
first component
in this example
of the composition of chart map
and curve but but the curve isn't gamma
here.
It is
sigma X
first component
they are of the derivative
evaluating at the point zero.
And of course
just get a 1 because
this is X composed with sigma X because
X is just the identity map
and the derivative gives 1.
The same for the second component.
Second component
again
gives 1 here.
Now these are the components of the
curve sigma X
with respect to the X chart.
Now turn to the Y chart.
Or to them.
Actually
we consider the second curve, which
we constructed using the Y chart, but in
order to compare vector components, we
have to use the same chart here. So,
we will calculate the components with
respect to the X chart again.
Again, the definition.
Now, sigma Y, first component derivative
at zero,
will again just yield one because this
is the first component of the curve
sigma Y.
One.
And now, the second component.
It's also defined like this.
And this gives
zero.
Here, we have product rule.
So,
we get
1 * e ^ - lambda
at zero.
At zero, this gives one.
And then, we get lambda
* - e ^ - lambda if we
insert zero, this gets zero. So,
1 + 0 is again one.
And we see
the components
of both curves
with respect to the same chart X
are the same.
And therefore,
the corresponding vectors are the same
cuz
the components
give the whole expansion of the vector.
For example, V sigma
X
at the point
P.
P is just 1 1, the intersection point.
was just
these components
and
the basis vectors.
And the second expansion, of course,
looks
Uh, I'm so I'm sorry.
And
we just checked
that
these objects
are the same
as
these.
So,
the whole linear combination stays
the same.
And
those two
velocities
coincide.